be good boy be a good boy I'm so happy  to have Stephie home it was a long few  weeks I'm always worried about her  because condition I'm just happy she's  back and she's healthy so how was your  trip it was it was good yeah I'm sure  I'm just so happy that you're back and  you're safe I can't wait to get home and  I can't wait to hear what you know all  the stories you can tell me about  all right well I'm exhausted so let's no  let's just go home my mom knows that  Erica's my friend and that's it and it  really bothered Erica towards the end  that I didn't know when I would come out  to my mom my suitcases are so heavy it's  hard because I've had this really  emotional experience and I am sad and  all I really want to do is talk to my  mom about it but I can't so it's a  lonely feeling  [Music]